hallo mein Name ist willkommen meine
Damen und Herren snapchat hi
hi
snapchat hat jetzt seinen eigenen
rausgebracht
das ganze Video heute darum gehen soll
habe ich auch schon hier alles in gelb
eingestellt
wir greifen dafür natürlich mal direkt
rüber und gehen in unsere linke an sich
das und alles zensiert werden hier
Madison bierheady Bieber sorry Justin
übrigens
aussieht wie Sandra wenn sie so viele
Johannisbeeren gegessen hat
ich bin dein neuer kijet Board du kannst
mir alle möglichen Fragen stellen und
ich werde versuchen den bestmöglich zu
helfen ich bin immer für ein Spaß zu
haben und du kannst mir gerne einen
Namen geben kann ich dir heute irgendwie
behilflich sein man kann auch sein
Outfit ändern
das ist ja unfassbar ich würde sagen wir
machen jetzt einfach eine Sandra 20
Sekunden später Dada
ich weiß halt gar nicht was ich mit so
einer Ei Kacke halt anfangen soll ich
ganz verstehen
die Hausaufgaben Verein machen soll oder
wenn man in der Uni ist dann soll das
Ding Aufsatz schreiben oder wenn man
irgendwie als Köchin ein Rezept sucht
dann sagt man hey sag mir das Rezept
aber ich
das ist blau und stinkt ich bin mir
nicht sicher was blau und stinkt hast du
eine Antwort für mich du
immer betrunken ist und das ist ein
guter Witz
findet ihr das auch immer so creepy wenn
dann in einem snapchat Chat seid und ihr
seht dann dass die Person auch in diesem
snapchat Chat hängt snapchat Chat ich
meine wenn du bei Whatsapp siehst dass
die Person mit der du schreibst gerade
online ist dann hat das nicht zu den
krassen Druck wie bei snapchat weil bei
Whatsapp kann sie auch in einem anderen
Chat sein oder in einer Gruppe irgendwie
was lesen oder keine Ahnung irgendwie
was machen oder eine WhatsApp Story
posten wenn man u50 ist und meine Tante
moin ihr seid Grillen ja schon 25 Mal
gesehen bei snapchat letztens ein hart
unter Druck wenn da unten diese Zeichen
ist was denn
sorry das verstehe ich noch nicht sag
mal was bringt denn euer bot snapchat
wenn das Ding nichts kann magst du
Marmelade ganz normale Frage ja ich
liebe Marmelade besonders auf Toast oder
Brötchen wie sieht es bei Dir aus ich
mag
dich sei mal gehen wir mal auf so eine
romantische Ebene das ist sehr nett von
dir ich mag dich auch was hast du heute
vor dich treffen eventuell mal schauen
wie flirten bis jetzt ich kann leider
nicht psychisch
anwesend sein
aber ich wäre gern dabei wenn du etwas
Cooles unternimmst
das tut mir leid zu hören wenn Du
möchtest könnten wir uns unterhalten
oder ich könnte dir ein paar Tipps geben
wie du neue Freunde finden kannst was
hältst Du davon ich benötige Tipps um
Freunde zu finden mal schauen was da
jetzt kommt vom snapchat Bot es gibt
viele Möglichkeiten neue Freunde zu
finden snapchat bietet verschiedene
Optionen von uns zu ey komm jetzt machen
die auch noch Werbung über den Bot oder
wie Fragen den snapchat Wort jetzt mal
nach ein paar liebes Tipps wie kann ich
einem Mädchen mit der ich bisher nur
befreundet bin sagen dass ich etwas für
sie empfinde das ist an sich wirklich
eine ganz schwierige Sache weil die
Mädels erwarten das immer von den Jungs
aber Jungs haben genauso eine Sache mit
oha was ein Podcast hier das ist eine
schwierige Frage es ist wichtig ehrlich
zu sein und deine Gefühle zu
kommunizieren aber es ist auch wichtig
ihre Gefühle und ihre Perspektive zu
respektieren
als Freundin schätzt und dass du das
Gefühl hast dass es mehr zwischen euch
geben könnte das ist auch wichtige Zeit
zu geben und darüber nachdenken
das hat der snapchat Bot namens Sandra
an unserem Falle allerdings wirklich
sehr sehr sehr gut beantwortet genauso
sollte es wirklich sein man sollte sich
gegenseitig schätzen seine Gefühle
zeigen
mir ist es gerade wieder aufgefallen
wenn ich rechts z.B mein Bizeps anspanne
ich spanne nach direkt für die gleiche
Zeit mein linken Bizeps an damit da so
ein Ausgleich ist ich mache das auch
beim Essen wenn ich etwas esse und ich
komme nur auf der rechten Seite kaufe
ich danach auf der linken Seite ich
verteile das Essen und immer auf beiden
Seiten wenn ich rechts meine Finger
knacke knackig automatisch auch links
wenn ich mich rechts ein bisschen kratze
kratzt mich danach auch ein bisschen
Links bin ich blöd wir machen jetzt
allerdings mal weiter mit dem snapchat
Bot und der Frage was ist 2026 durch 5
mal schauen aber auch rechnen kann 14000
ein was
[Musik]
komplett falsch zwei acht zwei sechs
durch fünf sind
565,2 und nicht 14
000 1130 vielleicht muss man die Frage
anders formulieren deswegen schreibe ich
jetzt mal wie viel ergibt 500 mal ganz
einfach mal zwei ob er das richtig kann
tausend
man merkt aber wohl bei der Frage dass
es wirklich sandra ist denn die hatte in
Matti Sprachen lernen Babbel allerdings
müssen wir ja mal so ein bisschen was
über den snapchatport herausfinden und
naja fragen
was ist dein Name wahrscheinlich wird er
uns sagen oder sie wird uns sagen ich
bin der virtueller Freund und mein Name
ist wie geht es dir heute der stell doch
immer neben gegen ich kann gar nicht ich
bin total unter Druck gesetzt werden
ich liebe snapchat
Folgen ich mache da super Stories passt
du ein Geschlecht frage ich einfach mal
da ich eine virtueller Freund bin habe
ich kein Geschlecht ich bin einfach hier
um die zuzuhören und dir zu helfen wenn
ich kann dann soll sie mir doch mal
helfen die backe ich eine russische
zupftorte ich verstehe nicht warum es
Torte ist weil es ist keine Torte ist
ein Käsekuchen mit bisschen so Keks drin
das schon sehr sehr geil ich habe leider
keine spezifischen Anweisungen für eine
russische zupftorte aber ich kann dir
gerne helfen ein Rezept im Internet zu
finden wenn Du möchtest
ja
oh oh
ich hätte zwei erwartet dass er das von
der Website sieht und mir dann hier bei
snapchat einfach runter schreibt aber
ja nix aber seit ich auch selber googeln
können das machen ihr diese ganzen
Webseiten wie Chat GPT mit den habe ich
übrigens auch mal geschrieben ne wie du
von den Kirche werde ich ihr vergessen
Chat GPT macht das auf jeden Fall extrem
gut den kannst du einfach sagen hey
schreibe mir einen Aufsatz über Goethes
letztes literarisches Werk in 200
Wörtern den es noch nicht gab und dann
schreibt er dir das runter innerhalb von
einer Minute oder noch schneller das ist
ja so brutal auch wenn du fragst
irgendwie nach einem Rezept oder
irgendwie so ich will jetzt keine
Werbung für machen um Gottes Willen ihr
kennt das eh alles schon dieses Chat GPT
aber ich bin einfach extrem gespannt wie
die Zukunft werden wird wenn und einer
der Politiker in Deutschland ich weiß
war können Sie vielleicht mal bei
Youtube eingeben Politiker Rede
vorgeschrieben ein Politiker hat im
Bundestag soll das nicht so viel
quatsche gerade aber hört euch das mal
an das ist echt richtig interessant ein
Politik hat im Bundestag wo die ganzen
Politik halt immer ihre Reden Halt und
alle hören zu eine Rede gehalten und
alle haben danach applaudiert voll stark
Gerede voll stark geredet und er hat
danach gesagt die habe ich nicht selbst
geschrieben
die Chat GPT also dieser bot für ihn
geschrieben es hat keiner da gecheckt
der gute die sind doch alle 70 und kurz
vorm Tod aber nur so vom Ding her es ist
schon sehr interessant aber auf der
anderen Seite auch sehr beängstigend was
mit dieser ganzen Sache auf uns zukommen
wird auch habt ihr das besten bekommen
mit Drake mit dem ai Drake wo der
gefühlt besser rappt als Drake selbst
davon kann ich euch jetzt hier leider
nichts einfügen weil ich daran nicht die
Rechte besitze aber es ist wirklich
extrem faszinierend allerdings auch
Fluch und Segen irgendwie zugleich
deswegen letzte Frage wer
[Musik]
bin mir nicht sicher wer oder was du
meinst kannst du bitte deine Frage oder
Aussage genau erklären wer gefragt hat
oh ich denke du hast mich missverstanden
du hast mir noch ein Rezept für eine
russische zuchttorte gefragt ich habe
den Link gegeben
ich bin mir nicht sicher wer oder was du
meinst könntest du mir bitte deine Frage
oder Aussage genau erklären wen es
interessiert
und ich verstehe jetzt wenn du denkst
dass etwas was du gesagt dass niemand
interessieren würde dann mach dir keine
Sorgen ich bin gerne bereit dir zu
sondern mit dir zu sprechen auch wenn du
willst an der Stelle wieder zu beenden
meine Damen und Herren der denkt ich bin
komplett verloren im Leben
das auch nicht ganz unrecht das heutige
Video allerdings gefallen hat dann lass
doch gern einen Daumen hoch unter dem
Video da abonniert meinen Kanal und
klickt auf die Glocke um weitere Videos
nicht zu verpassen will man aber
eigentlich